Alex Sol, Actor/Director: Fundamentally the
most common thing you would get in the beginning
before you got somebody really excited for
you for whatever reason is…they would open
the meeting like this:
“You know I don’t really have a place
for you.
I don’t really have a place for you.”
This is the opening of the meeting.
So you’ve sat down “Hey, Alex how you
are doing?
Great…so you were in American History X…Yes…yeah
great…I love that director.
Yeah…yeah…me, too.
He’s great.”
And then fundamentally you just really want
to say “What are we doing here?
What’s the point of this?
Do you want me?
Do you not want me?”
I want the meeting to go like that.
What do you want to do?”
I wish it were more direct but so the opening
statement would be this…then we’d get
through all the niceties and then “I’m
not going to be able to take you.”
And then we go on for another 40 minutes of
the meeting.
That’s a real horrible feeling because at
that point for me I just want to say “That’s
cool.
I respect that.
I’d like to leave now.
But you can’t do that.
So you have to sit there and do this ridiculousness
for another half an hour as you’re sitting
there going I’d have to talk to you if you
just told me you want nothing to do with me.
So yeah, those are annoying things.